- Can you give me some light, you got it?
All right, we got some
Pommery champagne here
in Amsterdam, we're leaving it
'cause we can't take it with customs.
So people just gotta find 'em.
Somebody's just gonna get
some free champagne tonight.
Those bubbles though!
♫ We're unstoppable
(atmospheric hip hop music)
- Literally the last fuckin'
seven emails in my inbox
are fake titles.
- [Man] Like "thank you so much?"
- Like "thank you,"
or like, I don't know,
the wine tweet I had,
like wine, "I really want wine."
"Can you review my app?"
Or like New York Jets thing,
like I'm just kidding, I
wanna get your attention,
can you give me four million dollars?
- [Man] That's the worst.
- I'm the last person
that shit's gonna work on.
Trying to teach.
- [Man] The cornerstone of what you teach,
like going against it.
- Yeah man you super
appreciate my hustles,
I trick you here, yeah.
I super appreciate it.
(all chuckle)
You got me, Rick.
I think you're amazing.
- [Man] Fuckin' Rick.
- Fuckin' asshole.
(all laugh)
- So here we are, it's
4:22 p.m. in Amsterdam
on the way to the conference.
Super excited about this.
Also, getting some texts
from my friend Harper
who I haven't seen in a long time
so I'm gonna try to connect with him.
A guy who I met when he was at Threadless,
do you remember Threadless,
the t-shirt site?
Best dude ever.
Got a quick phone call right now
with my Ruby Tuesdays client.
And then the keynote, the Q and A,
and then I get to depart
and I got a phone call
with a potential Vader Sports client.
And for the last four hours
I've been laying in the hotel
just doing a ton of VaynerMedia calls,
operations operations operations,
I'm sure Babben's got some b-roll.
Let's show it,
because I want them to see
the boredom of the operations.
(voices murmur on phone)
Sure.
Hi, sorry.
- I'm Esther.
- Thank you.
- No that's okay.
- I'll bring you back home.
- Thank you.
Can somebody tell me who's in the audience
so I can get a little bit of a sense?
Hey Rob.
- [Man] This is Rob, Rob, Gary.
- [Rob] Rob Ransom.
- Such a pleasure, how are you?
- Good to meet you.
- Good to meet you man.
- Thanks for coming all the way.
- Yeah, no worries, thrilled to be here.
- The other theme is
cross-cutting around technology,
that this is, the world's
moving fast, right?
And it's not just,
can you manage an AdWords
campaign anymore, right?
It's algorithmic stuff,
it's artificial intelligence,
and there's a theme a little bit
which our interests, which you've guessed.
Hey, you need to partner with someone
'cause the world's moving way to fast
for a small hotel company.
- Makes sense.
YouTube, it's the calm before the storm.
Hey Brandon. Wine Library.
Hold one one second.
YouTube, it's the calm before the storm.
I'm about to go out here in Amsterdam
and destroy their faces.
Sorry, Brandon, how's it going today?
- [Announcer] So please
welcome to the Click stage,
join me in a big, warm round of applause
for Gary Vaynerchuk, thank you.
(drums beat)
- Hello.
(crowd applauds)
Thank you.
First of all, this is beautiful.
I'm thrilled to be in this amazing city.
I'm really, really happy
to be in front of you.
And I gave a lot of thought backstage
and on the flight out here last night
on what I wanted to address.
And it was interesting for me to think
about the theme that really drove me
during that thought process,
which is ironically a
pretty interesting word
which is "practicality."
- [Woman] Right.
- Instead of like,
instead of hyperbole in either direction,
like this is the great,
everything's changed,
or the other way, none
of it fuckin' matters,
the kind of cross-section of the two.
Like how do you sell a hotel room today?
Yeah, I agree with you, the
last 10 minutes is good right?
- [Man] Yeah, I think so.
Bring this over here,
'cause I've got a theme.
There's always that moment
when there's finally
a little bit of trust,
once they realize that this
agency is really a proxy
for me to do something else
and I'm not just trying
to get their scope.
Once they get comfortable,
once we get comfortable,
every one of them starts to talk
about all the things that they're doing
that they don't believe in.
And let me leave you with this
because I've been watching a
lot of head-nods in this room.
It is far more fun to die on your sword
than to die on someone else's.
I'm inspired, YouTube,
we're gonna make this the episode thing,
you'll get whatever you want, Tyler,
but this is the fucking core of it.
You just saw it on stage.
(phone rings)
- Oh sorry.
You just saw it on stage.
Dying on your sword is better
than dying on someone else's.
So many of you are doing
things, making decisions
and navigating your lives
based on somebody else's thesis;
you're doing it because you
think it's the right thing,
because your dad's telling
you it's the right thing,
you're doing what you're doing right now
'cause you're pandering to your boss
even though you don't believe in it.
This is how it's gonna play out.
You are doing things, right now.
Yesterday you made a decision
that you don't believe in.
But you're smart, you did it
because you know how your company scores.
Here's the problem with
disruption in innovation.
Right now, you're being
rewarded for being a yes-person.
And in 36 months,
you're gonna be fired
for being a yes-person.
And you're doing it 'cause you just need
the security of your job.
I'm telling you, right the fuck now,
if you're watching this vlog
and you've got like, that
means you have a certain DNA,
please, I implore you,
please die on your sword,
not somebody else's.
If you're gonna lose, it's much more fun
to lose based on what you thought.
Do you know how many of you are gonna lose
on somebody else's thesis?
It's gonna kill at you,
it's gonna eat at you,
it's going to be the
worst fucking feeling,
so please, fuckin' pause
this video right now
and ask yourself, am I
doing my shit because of me?
Then you're good, whether
you're winning or losing.
Or am I doing it because somebody else
is telling me it's the right way?
Or, I'm subconsciously pandering
to please somebody or something
because I need the short-term stability?
Figure that the fuck out.
You know it, and I know it.
You just need to do something about it.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Sorry guys, YouTube, listen to this.
I put out a post about, you know,
stop blaming other people,
start blaming yourself.
I'm reading the comments right now.
It's super fascinating.
Of course, you know,
so my whole thing is like,
blame myself for everything.
Of course there's other
things that people are doing.
Right, like if somebody runs
me over with a car right now
and they were drunk,
is that my fault or is that their fault?
I get that you can
blame that other person.
I'm not so much worried about
the actuality of the event,
I'm talking about the fucking mindset.
Tyler, when are people gonna understand
this is the mindset,
the mindset of blaming yourself
allows you to do so much more
so when it's eight out of 10 times on you
you're moving forward
instead of looking backwards.
Sure, the two out of 10, but
if you just have that mindset
it's a winner mindset.
This is about mindset,
everybody's taking every
word I say so practical.
Yes, I understand that
there's issues in the world.
Like, it wasn't your
fault that an earthquake
like drilled your house.
I get it, it's the mindset.
To me I'd be like, man,
I shouldn't have lived
in fucking California.
I don't know, like, mindset.
It helps you eight out of 10 times
and the other two times you
just fuckin' deal with it.
Rant over.
What I wanted to do with this session
is mainly do Q and A,
as broad or as detailed
as you'd like to go.
I always find it funny,
luckily for me the world keeps changing
and the platforms keep changing
but the six or seven things I believe in
pretty much stay the same.
So in environments like this,
given that it's a smaller group,
I'd like to take the advantage
and I think you should be selfish
and go very narrow, 'cause I still think
30, 40, 50, 60% will share in that
and I think we have enough time here
to get to a lot of stuff.
So I'd like to open it up to Q and A
with anything that I referred to
or anything that you may have in your mind
that's overall digital.
The only time I've been really booed
was at South by Southwest 2010 I think,
when one of my opening lines was
"Jeff Bezos is much
better than Steve Jobs."
And I got booed.
Because I was such a fan of
the way he was navigating
and obviously he's
grown in so much stature
over the last couple years.
Alexa not only is gonna
be booking hotel rooms,
Alexa has the potential to kill Google.
Guys, one in every four searches on Google
is done by voice.
Excuse me, one in every
four searches on Google
in a mobile device is done by voice.
Notice how even the way I said it,
I don't even believe in
a desktop world anymore.
Yeah, you're damn right.
I mean, think about this,
back to what you were talking
about earlier, family,
let's play it out, families
having dinner, right,
talking about, where are
we gonna go this summer?
Right, blah blah blah?
Alexa, what's the, I mean,
the friction is zero.
Now, Google Home might win.
Google's biggest concern
in the world is Amazon.
Because the next search engine is voice,
and Alexa's ahead.
Can you give me some light, you got it?
All right, we've got some
Pommery champagne here
in Amsterdam, we're leaving it
'cause we can't take it with customs
so people just gotta find 'em.
Somebody's just gonna get
some free champagne tonight.
Those bubbles, though!
(restaurant patrons chatter)
What's up YouTube,
sitting here with Bavin.
I still think better D-Rock.
And Jordan, I think better than Mike.
(all laugh)
The 2.0s, anyway sitting here
in a restaurant in Amsterdam.
You know it's interesting,
I don't get a lot of
downtime on my trips, ever.
This is actually weird, this 20 minutes
sitting here and having a
beer or a protein shake.
Jordan's around.
And I'm enjoying it,
I'm gonna start trying to hack my culture,
my culture, hack my life,
and try to get these 20
minutes on these trips.
You know, I got Amsterdam and Turkey,
and flew to Hong Kong, and
I never really go there.
So just even 20 minutes of hacking,
so making commitment to
the YouTube audience,
20 minutes of hacking,
you know it's always like,
either work all the
way through and travel,
or do a meetup, which means I'm working
even at a higher level, and
even though I want to do meetups
and things of that nature
in every market that I'm in,
just having 20 minutes
to get a little deeper
with my homies, do a little work, enjoy,
meet some of the cool peeps
that are around here, these Amsterdamians,
is cool, so I'm gonna do that.
Always get better, always.
(relaxed hip hop music)
Those bubbles, though!